(audience cheers)
- Thank you!
- Find that dress in a slightly bigger size
and own it, 'cause it's so great!
- Isn't this cute?
Well, this is my second time on this show.
- Yeah.
- The first time on this show, I went out
and bought a fancy dress for you.
- [Kelly] Yeah, this is not the, this is cute!
- This was $42 on the internet.
(audience cheers and applaud)
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [Whitney] Ever since weed became legal,
I dress like a psychic in Santa Fe, going through a divorce.
(audience laughs)
- I love you!
You're pulling it off!
- It's kind of cute, right?
- I love it, the horses.
I love it.
Hey, you go on the road quite a bit.
Do you ever visit any national parks?
- You know what?
I don't, because I don't exercise,
- Yeah.
- [Whitney] 'Cause I hurt myself.
I rolled my ankle at the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
(audience chuckles)
and everyone was like, "You're not allowed
"to do anything active anymore."
My health insurance is just not good enough!
(audience chuckles)
- So do you like being on the road?
- [Whitney] I love touring!
I love, love, love touring, but I'm terrible at logistics.
- Oh!
- I'm bad at math.
Like, we're artists, and we're expected--
- Do you need to be good at math?
- Well, I have to sometimes post on social media
where I'm going and I mess up the dates.
Like, I'm going to Miami, right?
And I'm posting 22 cities and I'm like,
"I can't wait to come to Miami!"
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Everyone's like, "We can't find the tickets."
I'm like, "I don't know what's going on!"
I find out I'm going to Miami, Oklahoma!
(audience groans incredulously)
(audience laughs)
- There's a Miami, Oklahoma?
- [Whitney] First of all, it's pronounced, "Miam-uh".
(laughing)
It's not Miami, it's "Miam-uh"!
National Parks Guy, do you know what I'm talking about?
- National Parks Guy!
(audience laughs)
- [Whitney] Do you know what I mean?
(audience claps)
It's called Miami, Oklahoma, and I was like,
"Okay, I'm going to Miami, right?"
But, in the email they kept writing Miami, OK.
OK!
- Oh like, "Okay?"
- [Whitney] And I'm like, "Okay, book it!"
(audience laughs)
- Yeah!
- And then it's, "OK is Oklahoma."
- Oh my gosh!
- [Whitney] Yeah, so I just can't be trusted
to do my own--
- You can't be trusted?"
- Schedule!
But, I am gonna go to Miami, Florida at some point.
I love go--
You've performed in Miami.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I mean, it's the best!
They party!
- They're a fun audience!
- They party and--
- Like it doesn't matter how much you suck,
they're still drunk and just having such a good time.
- [Whitney] Yeah, such a good time!
Well, they don't need you to be there!
(audience laughs and cheer)
So Miami, a lot of time people wanna come and film shows now
and with stand-up, it's a little tricky
'cause you're like, "I don't want this to go on YouTube
"before I shoot a special."
And there were these girls that were filming during
the show and I didn't want them to post it,
and someone to take it down, so I was like,
"You know what, girls?
"Can you maybe stop filming,
"we can take pictures together at the end?"
And they looked at me going,
"Oh, we're not...
"We're not filming you.
"We're filming ourselves."
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Well thanks for paying attention!
That drives me nuts sometimes!
And I don't care if people film wherever.
But, it's just like, can we just be present?
- [Whitney] No.
- Like in the moment?
- [Whitney] Need the proof.
- Is it okay for you to put it down?
(laughs)
Nothing will happen!
Well, I don't know, in this day and age,
politically, something might happen!
(laughs)
I don't know what'll happen.
But it's just, I don't know.
People are crazy.
But what do people say to you, like fans?
You groupies, you tour, so--
- I feel very lucky because I do stand-up,
I share a lot of my personal stuff,
I do podcasts, so a lot of people know a lot about me.
So, people feel very comfortable coming up to me
in public and sharing intimate details about themselves
'cause I've done it.
And people will just come up to me at airports
and they'll be like, "I have two kids
"and I like one better than the other one!"
- [Kelly] Oh my--
- And they'll just walk off!
(audience gasps)
- "And I like one better than the other one?"
- [Whitney] Other one!
I had one woman tell me--
- You don't say that!
Or think that!
- [Whitney] 'Cause I share so much intimate stuff
about my life, I think people
feel like they should share it with me.
One woman was like, "Sometimes I hide in my car
down the street so I don't have to see my kids!"
(audience laughs)
- You know what?
Okay, that one, I understand.
(audience laughs)
That's what I do.
No, just kidding!
- She was like, "I pretend I'm running errands
"and I just hide in my car."
I'm like, "That's kind of a like hack."
- That's like, I'm like,
"Oh, Mommy's gotta go to the bathroom."
Like, 40 minutes later,
(laughs)
I have not been in the bathroom!
- Just napping on the toilet!
- I just wanted to lay down down!"
(audience claps)
So I did not know this last the time you were here.
But I heard that you have done an impression of me.
- I can't believe I'm even telling you this!
When I first moved to Los--
- I wanna hear it!
- I don't wanna tell you this!
Remember the show Mad TV?
- [Kelly] Yes!
- When I first moved to Los Angeles,
I auditioned for Mad TV and I don't do characters.
I don't do impressions.
But, I loved your music video for Since You've Been Gone.
- Me too!
- Where you were just freaking out for three minutes!
- I got to break things all day and got paid for it!
(laughs)
- And so I was like, "I'm just gonna do
"an impression of Kelly Clarkson!"
and I went in the audition room
and I just started throwing stuff around,
and smashing stuff, and screaming, and going nuts.
And I did not get the job!
(audience laughs)
- Shocking!
Shocking!
(laughing)
I just took a bunch of Adderall
and just went crazy basically.
(laughs)
And looking back now, you know when
you look back at things you did in your early 20s?
- [Kelly] Yes.
- I can't believe they didn't call the police.
- [Kelly] Yeah. (audience laughs)
Are you any better at auditions now?
- [Whitney] No!
No!
(audience laughs)
Not great at... I just start getting sweaty.
I get too anxious at auditions.
- [Kelly] Oh!
You're so great, though!
- [Whitney] Thank you!
- Okay, yeah.
- I agree!
(audience laughs and cheers)
- I agree, I'm amazing!
So, when you go on the road, do you take anything,
'cause I do, do you take anything special on the road?
- When I'm on the road... I am not a game, on the road!
I pack.
I bring my own microphone on the road.
- Your own microphone?
- I bring a microphone with me, so I'm not sharing
a microphone with 300 road comics.
So, I'm not getting--
- [Kelly] Oh, and them spitting--
- Weird, nasty, you know. - [Kelly] Yeah!
I've never thought about that!
- You gotta bring your own mic!
- Oh, I do that at radio shows
and all the artists get up there.
I have to share a mic.
That's disgusting!
- [Whitney] Oh yeah, there's old lipstick on it,
and just nasty chin beard pubes!
- [Kelly] I have my people take care of me
and I don't have their mic.
(laughs)
Okay, that's gross.
But, do you take anything else?
- [Whitney] Well, you do have to be careful
in the airport when a microphone goes through TSA,
(laughs)
a lot of times, they don't know it's a microphone!
(audience laughs and claps)
So, you really have to stop and be like,
"This does not vibrate, it's not battery op--
"That is a microphone, I swear!"
- You're like, "But if it did vibrate..."
(laughs)
- [Whitney] Yeah, I mean look, if they make that product,
I'm not gonna freak out!
- Yeah, that's your problem!
- [Whitney] Call Shark Tank, by the way!
(laughs and claps)
- Mark Cuban, listen!
(laughs)
So, I hear you love Nashville.
You love stopping in Nashville.
- [Whitney] I'm obsessed with Nashville!
I'm gonna be in Nashville on the tour.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I love going to Nashville because of the vintage stores.
- They have the best vintage shopping.
But I think I might stop doing it,
'cause last time I went, I got this awesome denim jacket.
It had all these patches on it and pins.
And I wore it all the time on Instagram.
I have a horse and I ride my horse in this jacket.
And I loved it so much, and I got this DM one day,
from this guy who was like,
"Hey, my ex got mad at me and sold
"a bunch of my stuff to a vintage store."
(audience gasps)
I think you have--
- First of all, that's awesome!
- I know!
(audience laughs)
- How have I not thought of that?
That is amazing!
You're trashing your stuff, plus making profit!
- Totally!
This woman is an entrepreneur and she sounds awesome!
And so, he said, "Can I have it back?"
And I was like, "Yeah, I guess."
So I sent it back to him.
- [Kelly] Did you tell him, "For this amount of money,"?
- I know!
- I mean, I bought it!
Sorry, she's a turd, but...
- [Whitney] I know!
So that, and then the other thing about going to the South,
is I'm still trying to figure out what everything means.
And you could probably help me
with the Southern colloquialisms.
- Yes.
What does, "Bless your heart," mean?
(audience chuckles)
- Mm, mm.
- Does it, it means you're stupid!
(audience chuckles)
- Well, there's like, it depends on the tone.
- [Whitney] Yeah!
- And who you're saying it to.
- [Whitney] Okay, so when I go to the South,
they'll ask me where I'm from and I'm like,
"I live in L.A."
And they're like,
- Bless your heart. - "Bless your heart."
(audience laughs and claps)
- Or it's like--
- [Whitney] What does that mean?
- It's... well it's not a compliment sometimes.
(laughing)
It's a Southerner's way of being shady.
- Yeah!
(laughs)
- But doesn't it sound nice?
It's like British people cursing you out.
It sounds nice. - That is so true!
- It's like, you know it's rude, but I like it.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
- And then I learned the hard way that when a woman
in the South says she's, "Fixin' to pitch a fit,"
- I'm fixin' to pitch a fit, yes.
- Get out of there!
- Yeah.
Get out of there!
Yup, and grab anything that belongs to you,
'cause she'll sell it, too!
(audience laughs and claps)
A Southern woman knows.
She's smart.
- And then also, is tea sweet already?
(audience laughs)
- No!
- If you want tea that's sweet, you just say,
"I'd like some tea."
- [Kelly] Well,
- But what if you don't want sweet tea?
- No, I've always been--
- Bless my heart?
- Bless your heart!
(audience laughs and claps)
- [Kelly] You know what, though?
I'm different.
I don't really do sweet tea anymore.
- [Whitney] Okay.
- Yeah, I just fell in love with hot tea.
- Okay,
- All my Southern friends just disowned me,
but I'm cool with that.
- I was gonna say!
(laughs)
- It's fine.
- She's gone full Hollywood!
- Yes, exactly, I'm so L.A. with my tea.
So, you have have thoughts on Valentine's Day, I hear.
- [Whitney] Well, yes.
Valentine's Day is coming up very soon.
And I feel like every year guys screw it up!
(audience laughs and cheers)
- Looking at you.
- Not the park guy.
Not the park guy.
So, I have some ideas for guys that
are watching the show that want some advice.
So, where am I looking?
Oh, I'm gonna look into here.
The guy up there, I'm looking at you, sir!
(audience laughs)
If you're buying a--
(cymbal crashes)
(audience laughs)
(band plays romantic music)
- [Kelly] No one warned you!
No one warned you!
All of a sudden my band just really wanted to be a part.
So they just started playing.
- Oh my God!
Oh God, okay!
- We are playing music under your PSA!
- [Whitney] Oh Geez!
(audience laughs)
Okay, all right.
Woo!
I'm sweating!
Look, I'm sweating now, look!
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] You are!
Ah, you can't see, it's black!
- Okay, advice for the guys.
You ready, goatee in the back?
You ready?
(laughing)
All right.
If you're buying ladies a gift for Valentine's Day,
get a gift card!
I know, it's impersonal!
Get a gift card!
I promise you,
(audience cheers)
I promise you.
I promise you, it'll be less of a fight
than buying something in the wrong size.
(audience applause)
Also, if you're buying something for your girlfriend
of two or more years, and decide to buy her jewelry
that's not an engagement ring, I suggest you give her
that jewelry box wearing a helmet!
(audience laughs)
'Cause you're about to get concussed, sir.
Godspeed!
(audience cheers)
- See?
Thank you.
- Godspeed.
- Thank you, Whitney!
- Good luck!
- [Kelly] Thank you for that PSA!
The best part was like, two years?
Wear a helmet, 'cause she gonna beat you beat you--
- When guys after two years are like,
"Here's a necklace," outta here.
- [Kelly] Outta here!
- Outta here.
- [Kelly] You take that jewelry and shove it!
(laughs)
Bless your heart! - Bless your heart!